[Music]
as part of our forbes 400 list this year
we decided to change the way we track
charitable donations from billionaires
typically we would count the money
people on the list have put in their
charitable foundations over a lifetime
instead we are now tallying the grants
made by those foundations
as well as tracking direct gifts this
gives us a more accurate picture of how
much america's billionaires have given
away
we also did not count money put into
donor-advised funds
this is because these tax advantaged
accounts do not have disclosure
or distribution requirements we only
took distributions from donor advise
funds into account when members shared
details about grants that were actually
paid
forbes also did not count money that has
been pledged but not given out
so with that all explained who gave the
most this year
when looked at in terms of dollars
donated warren buffett is the biggest
giver
we estimate that 40 billion dollars of
buffett's fortune which stands at 73.5
billion dollars in total
has been distributed to non-profits
primarily through the bill and melinda
gates foundation
each member of the forbes 400 was scaled
from one to five
based on their giving as a percentage of
net worth since buffett donated the most
he scored a five
hungarian billionaire george soros also
scored a five
since he has donated 64 percent of his
original income
in the threes we find ray dalio and
robert kraft
this means they've given away between
five percent and nine point nine
nine percent of their wealth and among
those who scored a one
meaning they've given away less than one
percent of their wealth
we find amazon founder jeff bezos and
walmart
heirs jim and rob walton in total
at least 171 billion dollars have been
given to charities and nonprofit
institutions by members of the forbes
and although 74 billionaires on the list
have signed to the giving pledge
promising to commit at least half of
their wealth to charity
only 10 people have actually scored a 5
on our giving scale
you